[Music]
Wow
we are in the land of the JavaScript
errs but you already knew that so today
I'm going to share some thoughts in a
medium that you probably weren't
expecting I know I'm not the first
person to bring poetry to a tech
conference and I sincerely hope I'm not
the last you see javascript and the
people who write javascript that's you
all have been essential to my work in
developer relations I've watched the
culture and the language evolve and grow
up over the past decade this is the
tweet that went out announcing my talk I
was so excited and so honored I decided
to embrace it even though I have never
ever thought of myself as a golden girl
and I had to wonder what would you all
be expecting from me so I struggled for
weeks trying to find a way into my story
and then one random Wednesday morning in
April after several weeks of waking up
in the middle of the night in the dark
and a cold panic I decided to get up and
write I began why is my brain so unsharp
this might be my last conference talk
ever and then I kept going as the light
crawled into the garden and the birds
started making noise
I wrote the Jay s conce were punk rock
they cut the crap and went rollerblading
then I stepped slowly away from the
display
I grabbed pad aligned legal pad and a
pen and started writing 14 lines later
it was a sonnet strict rhyme scheme a
meter called iambic pentameter that
sounds like the beat of your heart but
padam padam padam padam i felt lighter
than i had in weeks writing poetry had
put me into a fine state of flow this
was the first one the beginning here
goes when I consider Jay s confit you
and wonder what it is I have to share
heroic JavaScript errs I once knew or
Yui or Ajax or would you even care
I've studied coders long but not the
code I no constraint can free up
self-expression rhyme scheme metre
platform network node but is there room
on stage for true confession you see all
speak of cultures evolution but you are
the artisans of Jay s give and taking
and I'm not here to splain your
revolution it's iterative and comes from
daily making creating more than apps and
interactions you terraform immersive new
distractions you're gonna see this slide
at the close of every sonnet I'll read
nine of them are eight more of them
today it's a visualization of Lorenz's
strange attractor that's a set of
equations that describe a simplified
model of convection flow in the Earth's
atmosphere
the Lorenz attractor is also associated
for some obvious reasons with the
butterfly effect the unverified idea
that small changes of state like a
butterfly flapping her wings can
influence larger more significant
differences later and elsewhere like
triggering a tornado
thousands of miles away we'll get back
to that a little bit later in the talk
for now it turns out the constraints of
poetry are not totally different from
the constraints of code in producing
things of craft and artfulness
in a sonnet as in code you have to pack
a lot of meaning and intent into tightly
controlled syntax and word choice and
then there are elegant ways to go
bonkers and bend or break the rules
quick two-minute history of the sonnet
form it was created in Italy in the
early 13th century the poet patriarch
you may have heard of was its most
famous practitioner the form travelled
across Europe and arrived in England in
the early 16th century just in time for
the Elizabethan poets and Shakespeare
most famously of all who wrote 154
sonnets through the centuries poets
everywhere wrote sonnets in their own
languages in Russia in the early 1800s
Alexander Pushkin wrote a novel in verse
called Eugene Onegin 389 stanzas of
sonnet about the life and times of a
young romantic let's say in 1922 in
German in a chilly castle in Switzerland
the Austrian poet Rainer Maria Rilke
rode a 55 sonnet cycle called sonnets to
Orpheus in 1986 inspired by Pushkin
indian-born author Vikram Seth published
the Golden Gate
a tale of yuppie romance set in San
Francisco and written in Onegin stanzas
and he inspired me and so it goes the
sonnet indoors is a poetic form for
storytelling philosophizing expressions
of love and celebrations of festive
occasions the second sonnet the origins
story was inspired by a talk from young
Leonhardt called joyous conf history
written in 2015 the times have changed
with JavaScript's ascent since voodoo
Tiki God ten years ago pitched us to
sponsor a new event a gathering in
Washington
beyond the web 200 of suits and swag and
paid product pitches the first jazz con
happened in the spring and almost didn't
due to funding glitches but tickets sold
it was a homecoming for folks who didn't
know that content plus fun could raise
up a community of like-minded coders
where once was none it was not long to
find an opportunity to do another one in
pulsing Berlin jaan hoger Malta
Christina made the cons the gayest
concen CSS conf
pure win
in the Sun it's a head I'll continue to
poke at the relationship between the
writer's craft and the coders in
Elizabethan England poets would release
their sonnets in private to an elite
audience before sharing them more widely
kind of like I'm doing here today so
please be kind to these little songs of
mine like me they're travelers from an
older world into JavaScript world
domination of course trajectory is best
viewed in retrospect a j/s singularity
was never inevitable but loose
Federation makes Network effect and the
J's comps have been unforgettable
client-side server-side Dark Side of the
Moon Asia Australia Columbia Budapest
nodejs and Tito launched from this
cocoon Iceland Scotland CSS comps and
the rest it's that magic dynamic that
comes to your town building camaraderie
out of the fun maybe it is conferences
all the way down artifacts of knowledge
with access for everyone and always new
ideas are put in play to globally
influence a generations way one of those
good ideas that did not emerge
immediately was the need for a code of
conduct and a focused committed effort
to enforce it along with a commitment to
foster diverse an inclusive environment
for all attendees and all speakers we
can and we must keep doing better at
this and maybe this weekend I think this
weekend has shown me some of what's
possible so the code of conduct at our
events we do not tolerate harassment of
participants in any form a posted code
of conduct works to mitigate in 2011
this was far from the norm today we
raise each other up through schooling
for unbiased language and communication
appropriate kindness and respect and
tooling to promote good behavior and
collaboration we will not tolerate at
our events stalking or following or
unwelcome comments this in or unwelcome
contact this includes offensive verbal
comments you see a code of conduct as a
pact reminding each of us of our
humanity and hoping tolerance can
replace profanity okay and sonnet five I
look back in time Emma Lazarus was a
writer and an activist in New York City
well educated and well-to-do in 1883 she
wrote the sonnet that eventually found a
place on the pedestal on a plaque on the
pedestal of the Statue of Liberty in New
York City Harbor those are the words of
welcome for immigrants and refugees to
the United States a digital immigrant
that's me
reflects on Emma Lazarus the sonnet is a
poem of 14 line
give me your tired your poor your
huddled masses octave sestet pentameter
define the sonnets of Petrarch
shakespeare and emma Lazarus's new
colossus that made the Statue of Liberty
evermore a mother of exiles for every
refugee her lifted lamp beside the
Golden Door gives worldwide welcome to
the land of the free twenty years to go
from print to monument written in 1883
engraved on a plaque in 1903 a poem for
the immigrant by an author and an
activist a world-class harbor hack Emma
like me a New York City girl with Jewish
roots wielding words to change minds our
work is in codes tada this next poem was
inspired by a TED talk from Carole
Cadwallader an investigative journalist
for The Guardian whose work uncovered
the role and tactics of Cambridge
analytic and disrupting the brexit vote
on Facebook
I'll also quote from an article by
Jeffrey's elderman on a list apart title
nothing fails like success about the
dangers of surveillance as a business
model the immigrant who puts down roots
but never learns the language that's
JavaScript and me sometimes code is
poetry that changes lives forever though
nothing fails like success to keep us
free gathering wise words from Twitter
Ike
read I could weave sonnets of bravery
and 140 characters gleaned from
conferences recorded to retrieve later
to remember the passion of others
courage in the form of a TED talk by
Carol Cadwallader to the tech gods of
Silicon Valley sheer terror didn't stop
her speaking truth to power her urgency
to save democracy will we play with our
phones as this darkness falls
fascism Rises when democracy Pauls okay
I would not be here today if it weren't
for my employer Mozilla and I'm not
really sure that the web as we know it
would be here were it not for Mozilla so
this is a sonnet for Mozilla you may
know Mozilla as the dinosaur that burst
a browser open source out of Netscape's
ashes long may Firefox endure as a user
centric client with a mission worth your
love to protect the NED as a global
public resource Mozilla makes browsers
apps code and tools open and accessible
safe and free a force for opportunity
with level playing field rules keeping
tabs on browser culture and Internet
health explicit in our aspirations and
stated in our manifesto in support of
civil discourse collaboration and a
wealth of user commitments ten
principles plus addendum show a clever
red panda that faints like a fox
protecting web standards so the open web
still rocks
I met
Angus crawl at a j/s conference in Porto
Alegre Brazil in 2013 his book if
Hemingway wrote JavaScript was in the
works and he spoke then about the
connections between language literature
and JavaScript and I don't think this
talk would ever have happened without
that book I also quote directly from
some of anguses online writing about
code poetry and code and when I do this
I'm trying to indicate that I'm quoting
somebody else's words verbatim so
doctrine and dogma these are the enemy
of good JavaScript right Sanga scrawl a
programmer who codes English
expressively if Hemingway wrote
JavaScript for whom would it toll crawls
book praises pushing language boundaries
for earnest code works tersely and
direct his simplicity conceals the
quandary zuv eloquent reduction jane
austen's code is circumspect
if code is function and poetry is grace
if poetry connotes and code commands the
choice of paths reveals a human face an
algorithmic style is still in human
hands a 25 author pastiche goes beyond
the charm of ploy and lead led me to
write sonnets which I hope will spark
some joy
huh and so thank you for indulging my
book reviews and literary references
that may be a little unfamiliar they've
given me a way to share some reflections
on culture and code you may have noticed
also that in writing as in JavaScript we
are always borrowing and building upon
the writing and the work of others
especially the texts or the libraries
that that have shaped us and taught us
and tickle our fancy so there are
several slides of reference links and
one more book reviews on it called big
data big picture in the appendix and
also on the jeaious confi use sonnets
page which is live now online if you
really want to keep going I'm gonna
close with an homage to two programs
that are very dear to my heart and one
is Mozilla text speakers a program that
I co-founded and led for a few years and
that maybe also poised for world
domination like JavaScript and global
diversity CFP day a young program that
came about directly through the
influence of jazz cons and that's been
very present here this weekend
so then
Mozilla Tech speakers is a program
designed like global diversity CFP day
to make diverse speakers easier to find
and share skills tools and contacts
along the way CFP day workshops are
grassroots and self-sustaining built by
jiggy Pete to fill a lineup with new
faces
Mozilla's program offers support and
training for web advocates and speakers
from a host of places these are living
proof of working ecosystem standalone
programs launched and thriving feeding
global JavaScript momentum nomadic
tribes of advocates arriving is it the
butterfly effect or strange attractor
the influence of jazz cons could well be
a factor okay today I've been speaking
about the subtle and intelligent things
that are exchanged when people come
together with good intentions and a
certain spirit i've pushed past my own
sheer terror to share what i believe
most deeply that if you can be true to
yourself
there are many amazing and outrageously
cool things you can do from there like
organize a tech event and sixty cities
on the same day from an island and the
far north or write ten sonnets about
javascript in 21 days under pressure for
a tech conference so thank you so much
to everyone who's encouraged me on this
journey and thank you all today so very
very much
for your
tenshun I'll be putting the slide deck
up and like I said there's lots of
resource slides and links and one more
sonnet in there so have fun and yeah if
you're into John McCarthy and AI and
stuff you should read that one alright
thank you all so much really
[Music]